so i just finished the final episode of
the series and i'm like
and you fellas got something to drink
yeah i'm gonna need a drink after this
because i was not expecting this
ending there is a lot to unpack here
like who this woman was watching over
sabrina's death
where sabrina actually is and nick too
and about a half dozen hints at what we
can expect for a season five
yes the show has been cancelled on
netflix but there are clues that it may
be coming back
so make sure to like and subscribe
because hell is
waiting the final episode is called at
the mountains of madness which is both
the place sabrina and faustus work on
extracting the void as well as the name
of a famous
hp lovecraft novella guillermo del toro
has tried to adapt it into a movie for
decades but that's besides the point
lovecraft is a huge influence on this
season as the main horrors which plague
sabrina and greendale are the eldritch
terrorists whom were heavily inspired by
lovecraft's stories
in chapter 29 agatha even refers to
faustus blockwood as being reverend
lovecraft as he starts his new church
the pilgrims of the night
we would love it if you came to visit us
soon no thank you
part three saw blackwood pledging to be
the eldritch terror servant and here we
are picking up right where we left off
mary wardwell has taken on a new role
leading the pilgrims of the night after
the absence of reverend lovecraft who
she says
is currently on a holy mission she has
his book of writings which are called
the eldritch gospels we see him writing
these all the way back in chapter 29.
the attention to detail here is also
great as the church has grown
considerably since wardwell was first
introduced to it eight episodes ago the
interesting thing here is wardwell is
reciting events faustus blockwood
wrote down two days before halloween and
50 minutes later near the end of the
episode
she says this admorium
fastest glorium which translates from
latin to
happy to die for glory this seems to
suggest two things
one that faustus is dead but we'll get
to what happens to him later
and two that the events depicted in the
final episode were
written by blackwood himself so keep
that in mind
nick ends up giving sabrina a memento of
his love
dual lockets each containing a photo of
themselves
not only is this a symbol of his love to
her but it also plays an important plot
point later on in the episode
and as they passionately kiss in
sabrina's room nick is [ __ ] blocked by
sabrina morningstar who has returned
from the alternate cosmos
to warn them that the final eldritch
terror the void
is on its way it won't stop until
everything's
destroyed the eldritch terrors have been
the main focus of this season
and there are eight of them the darkness
the uninvited
the weird the perverse the cosmic the
returned
the endless and the void by the final
episode sabrina and the gang have pretty
much either
contained or stopped all of these tears
except for the most menacing of all
the void which seeks to destroy all
worlds including heaven
hell and mortal meanwhile faustus who
was beheaded and forced to look at his
own rotting body in the dungeon of the
academy
senses that it's time you may be
wondering how he's not dead
that's because in part 3 he was given
the mark of cain which granted him
immortality
that's also why prudence knowing this
ends up cutting his body and spreading
the parts around the globe
so this leaves plenty of opportunity for
wardwell and the pilgrims of the night
to search out for his parts and bring
him back together again now this finale
does this a lot purposely leaving out a
lot of story threads in case the show
were to be picked up for another season
on another platform and i'll try to
point these out as i go along
you'll notice faustus calls upon his
body to come toward him and some of you
may be like
why didn't he do this earlier that's
because he was waiting for this specific
moment
when the void would be on its way
there's no one that knows more about the
void than him so
this was all part of his plans sabrina
needs help trying to destroy the void
and guess who magically shows up
good evening to your friend yes trinket
man i'm the trinket man
this was one of the aspects of the show
which i didn't particularly like this
guy seems to show up anytime one of the
characters has a problem with an object
that will save everything kind of like
in chapter 32 where he gives ambrose
the stone of omfulos which allows him to
save greendale from emperor blackwood
this time he has something even more
powerful pandora's box
in greek mythology pandora's box was a
jar opened by the first human woman
pandora and when she
opened it things didn't turn out well it
contained
sicknesses death and many other evils
that would be unleashed upon the world
so sabrina is going to use this in the
hopes of trapping the void within the
only problem is she has to be
inside the void to do it meaning she
won't make it back
out she knows her future is death hence
why she writes a goodbye note to her
family but what sabrina doesn't foresee
is that while she's opening the box and
putting an end to the void
her family is performing a spell that
will bring her back the only problem is
they don't have her body so they use
sabrina morningstars who died from
crashing through the mirror
and put sabrina spellman's soul into it
so basically we have half mortal half
witch sabrina spellman's soul
put into the body of sabrina morningstar
the queen of hell
of course this pisses off lucifer who
learns from lilith that his daughter has
died and her body is being desecrated by
sabrina spellman's soul
lilith will tell lucifer where sabrina's
location is if he promises to give her
her powers back
remember back in chapter 33 that lucifer
stripped lilith of all her powers
after she refused to tell him where
their son adam was
and you don't want to know where he went
he is dead
caliban and biezelbub head into the
mines to gather an
army taking control of harvey's dad and
the miners
their attack on this spellman's don't go
over as planned as sabrina starts
sucking in her attackers faster than my
dyson i got for christmas
this freaks lucifer and he pieces out
telling lilith that sabrina has
god-like powers something even he can't
compete against but lilith wants lucifer
to make good on her deal
she told him where sabrina was and she
wants her powers back and when he
declines she stabs him in the back with
the one thing that can kill him
the spear of longinus longinus longinus
uh whatever it's the spear that pierced
the side of jesus as he hung on the
cross
believe it or not this spear was teased
as lucifer's downfall way back in part
two well planned but fruitless
only the spear of longinus could kill me
lilith then proceeds to drink lucifer's
celestial blood to regain her powers and
i would assume this also makes her queen
of hell
she banishes lucifer to wander the
mortal realm without his powers
just like he did to her and this is yet
another example of a story thread that
just kind of
ends if there's a season 5 expect
lucifer to make a return
and want revenge on lilith scans show
that sabrina's body is completely empty
when her soul was brought into its new
body part of the void latched onto it
hence why
random people and objects disappear
around her sabrina sees
no choice but to cast herself out to the
mountains of madness
so that she can no longer hurt anyone
else meanwhile the others concoct a plan
to save sabrina and end the void for
good but part of this plan involves
retrieving pandora's box and they have
no idea where it is
this is where nick's locket comes into
play because the two lockets are bound
together he can find out where her body
is
snatch the box and return home and nick
can go into the emptiness of space
and live because he was forged in the
fires of hell but he has to use an
eldritch tentacle thing in order for him
to breathe at the mountains of madness
sabrina is visited by blackwood who
claims he can teach her how to control
the void and perhaps
one day even get rid of it and sabrina
here doesn't really have a choice
after all there's no one who knows more
about the void and the eldritch terrors
than faustus blackwood two weeks later
and ambrose prudence roz and agatha
tracked down sabrina using her familiar
salem
sabrina herself looks completely drained
of power having to hold back the void
ambrose accuses faustus of trying to
unite the rest of the void with the
peace in sabrina so he can wield the
power all for himself
they ask for a trade all the eldritch
tears and pandora's box
in exchange for sabrina this would be
way more powerful for faustus
i settled for sabrina's poultry piece of
the void
but it is almost in its entirety here
faustus agrees but it's all a trap the
box is a fake rigged with gunpowder
blinding him in the process
the next step is where things get
complicated by cutting sabrina on this
altar and allowing her void infused
blood to drain around it
they can open a containment field for a
brief moment of time
nick ambrose and harvey take the
eldritch terrors through the field to
leave them there
while simultaneously searching for their
family members who disappeared hilda and
zelda also lock eyes with a mysterious
visitor
you might remember her as the dread
banshee from season 3
and she foreshadows a member of the
spelman's death
it's an omen sabrina i'm sorry but a
member of this bombing family is going
to die sir
nick and the gang successfully save
everyone from the void and i'm like i
hope those pancakes made it out too
and it's safely sealed away within
pandora's box but sabrina
doesn't make it we see her blood has
turned from white to red and wardwell's
voiceover transitions us to the funeral
of both sabrina's
zelda struggles with why their goddess
hecate didn't help sabrina
maybe that's because sabrina isn't dead
and even if she is there's always been
ways to bring back someone from it like
the cane pit or another thread left open
baron sandy in part four we learned that
mambo marie was in fact the head of the
loa spirits baron samdi
who gives zelda an object she can use to
summon him in case she ever needs
something
who better to raise someone from the
dead than the spirit who helps carry
those to the underworld but what we're
really wanting to know is
what happened to sabrina we see her in
the same void-like room but this time it
has some more cheerful and colorful
paintings the writing even says the
sweet hereafter and what about the void
isn't it trapped in pandora's box
so this can't be the void right it also
can't be heaven or hell
or else she'd just show up there the
paintings give us a little hint
i take these to mean the left being hell
the middle the apple tree from the
garden of eden the mortal world
and the right being heaven she is
somehow in between these three places
this is different than the void which
had pictures of
m.c escher paintings alluding to how
there was no escape
things just keep repeating over and over
in a vast
nothingness so we can assume this isn't
the void nor a place we've seen in the
sabrina universe before
then there's the introduction of nick
who alludes that he killed himself to be
with her
which is a bit problematic since it
romanticizes suicide
how did he get here wouldn't he be sent
to hell how did he know where she was
that's the problem with this ending it's
so open-ended and doesn't give us
closure on almost any of the characters
the emotion falls flat because of it
thematically the ending falls in line
with how sabrina's character arc is set
up at the beginning of part 4 sabrina
finds herself
alone everyone's moved on without me no
one loves you
no one could love you i still feel
alone she even tells lucas how she
doesn't know where she fits in the
universe i've just been having this
free-floating anxiety
like i don't know who i really am
anymore
and that's where we leave her at the end
alone and unsure of where she is
the addition of nick felt forced and
tacked on i felt like there was more
story to be told
in chapter 31 sabrina says i need to
figure out who i am
on my own but i didn't get the feeling
that she did that her character arc to
me was left
unfulfilled and i think part of the
problem here is that the writers don't
exactly know where the series is going
and had out of necessity
to leave it as wide open as possible in
case it gets renewed in a july 2020
tweet from executive producer roberto
aguerza casa
he said part 5 would take place via
comic and would be entitled witch war
and include the witches of riverdale but
in a more recent instagram post on
december 31
2020 he used the words quote the last
for now
episode hinting that something is in the
works for months it's been hinted that
the series will be picked up on hbo max
which owns the rights to the sabrina
property under warner brothers and if
you click on the distributor section of
imdb
guess who is listed as one of the
distributors hbo max
i really hope this show comes back it's
been a fantastic ride and i think these
characters
deserve a better ending than what we got
but that's just my opinion
what do you think of sabrina's maybe
final last season
i want to hear your comments and
theories below thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like subscribe and
share and check out my chilling
adventures of sabrina playlist below
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you